trenes y autobuses colapsados lugares
públicos sofocantes en la situación de
Nueva Delhi que podría empeorar la ONU
estima que india con una población
actual de un 2.300 millones de
habitantes reemplazará a China como el
país más poblado del mundo para 2023
el desempleo aumentará y debido a eso
Habrá más robos violaciones asesinatos
todo esto está sucediendo Deli no era si
hace cinco años la población ha
aumentado mucho No sé si pueda ir de
compras si entras en esta multitud se
vuelve difícil respirar es peligroso
el informe proyecta que para 2036 el 40%
de la población de India vivirá en zonas
urbanas una situación que se podría
salir de las manos y el país asiático no
invierte 840 mil millones de dólares
Durante los próximos 15 años en
infraestructura urbana empleo y planes
Contra el Hambre según advirtió el Banco
Mundial
en promedio cada mujer en India tiene
2.1 hijos registrando entre 60.000 y
70.000 nacimientos diarios los cuales
han logrado ser controlados en clínicas
y hospitales
antes la mortalidad era muy alta pero
ahora los bebés están mejorando los
bebés nacen cada vez más en hospitales y
no en las casas por eso sobreviven más y
estamos felices como médicos
el informe de la ONU también detalla que
el crecimiento de la población mundial
cayó por debajo del 1% en 2020 y Que
para 2050 más de la mitad del aumento
proyectado de la población mundial se
concentrará en la República democrática
del Congo Egipto Etiopía India Nigeria
Pakistán filipinas y tanzania